[Música]
un crecimiento que genera dudas de
manera sorprendente la economía de
venezuela ha comenzado a tener síntomas
de mejoría tras casi una década de
contracción hiperinflación cambios de
cono monetario y prácticamente una
dolarización de facto ni los organismos
internacionales se ponen todavía de
acuerdo en cuanto a las cifras veamos
algunas el fondo monetario internacional
estimó en sus previsiones a julio del
2022 un crecimiento para venezuela del
1.5 por ciento por su parte la comisión
económica para américa latina del caribe
la cepal dijo que el crecimiento sería
de un 5 por ciento mientras que el
observatorio venezolano de finanzas
indicó que el crecimiento estimado sería
de 12 3% en el primer semestre del año
pero incluso a nicolás maduro el
controvertido presidente de venezuela
dijo que la economía crecería o creció
en este primer semestre dos dígitos sin
dar una cifra específica las cifras
entonces como lo decíamos generan muchas
dudas porque el banco central de
venezuela no reporta datos no reporta
datos sobre el producto interno desde el
2019 por eso no se pueden contrastar
esta información no se pueden comparar
las cifras y no se pueden ver
indicadores o rendimientos económicos
por diferentes sectores lo cierto es que
sean cual sean las cifras están muy
lejos de esos valores económicos de
venezuela por ejemplo para el año 2012
cuando venezuela era la cuarta economía
más grande de latinoamérica por detrás
de brasil de méxico y argentina cuáles
son entonces los motivos de este
crecimiento hay varios motivos para
analizarlos vamos a profundizar a lo
largo del programa con nuestros
invitados pero algunos de ellos sería
por ejemplo el aumento de los precios
internacionales del petróleo también el
aumento en el número de remesas que
llegan a este país de los bolsillos de
los casi 6 millones de venezolanos que
han abandonado venezuela y también se
puede deber a más y mejores condiciones
para el acceso a créditos bancarios
también es cierto que hay un cierto
cambio en el rumbo de la política
económica del gobierno que lidera
nicolás maduró él mismo habló en su
momento de devolver esas empresas que
fueron expropiadas durante el gobierno
de chávez que fueron expropiadas por el
estado venezolano
pues prácticamente no logró mantenerlas
a flote y ahora quien saben que en
condiciones las quiere regresar a sus
dueños pero esto entonces se aleja un
poco del modelo estatista y ese modelo
socialista que querían imponer allí
incluso el mandatario apuesta por la
llegada de la inversión extranjera
veamos
en la toma y retoma
con un nuevo impulso el camino de la
construcción de zonas económicas
especiales como caminos para el impulso
del desarrollo de las fuerzas
productivas de nuestro país como camino
para la atracción de inversiones
productivas
que lleven al desarrollo científico
tecnológico industrial al desarrollo
elevado del comercio por parte de
nuestro país y se suma a todo este
panorama una oportunidad de oro la
crisis de suministro de gas y de
petróleo que está viviendo europa al
reducir la dependencia del suministro
procedente de rusia una crisis que
podría agudizarse en unos meses con el
inicio del invierno boreal maduro por
supuesto ya vio allí una oportunidad
yo le diría al presidente de macrón
presidente macrón venezuela está lista
para recibir a todas las empresas
francesas que quieran venir a producir
petróleo y gas para el mercado europeo
para el mercado mundial bien medido
cuando quieran el camino está hecho
estamos preparados preguntas sobre este
tema múltiples que tan necesitada y que
están dispuestas hasta europa de
suavizar entonces la relación con maduro
sólo por esa necesidad que tiene de
recibir gas y petróleo y esto cómo
repercutiría entonces para venezuela
porque crece la economía venezolana en
términos generales qué tan real es este
crecimiento que la sustenta cómo se
percibe entonces al interior del país
que dicen los ciudadanos de a pie que
hay de esa dolarización de facto hoy en
el debate de france 24 nos preguntamos
venezuela repunta la economía a qué se
debe
para analizar este tema saludamos a
tamara herrera ella es directora de
síntesis financiera y ya se encuentra en
la ciudad de caracas y también en la
capital venezolana según esta
conversación
morales él es economista senior en
ecoanalítica y profesor de estadística
de la universidad católica andrés bello
les recuerdo que ustedes también hacen
parte de esta conversación pueden dejar
todas sus preguntas y sus comentarios a
través de las redes sociales estamos en
twitter en instagram también en facebook
en donde nos encuentran como arroba
france24 y un bajo ese arroba santi logo
que es mi cuenta personal la etiqueta es
numeral el debate efe 24 también nos
pueden ver en vivo y en directo en
nuestra señal de streaming a través de
youtube y yo aprovecho para saludar a
las personas que nos están escuchando a
través de nuestro podcast los invito
para que escuchen todos los contenidos
de nuestro programa que ya están
disponibles en app el podcast en spotify
deezer y en junio
comienza entonces dándole la bienvenida
a tamara en la ciudad de caracas a
tamara gracias por estar con nosotros en
el programa punto de partida pregunta
básica la que hacía yo al inicio del
programa repunta la economía venezolana
a qué se debe
gracias por la invitación
bueno el repunte primero después de una
caída en barrena como nunca se conoce en
la historia contemporánea de una caída
en tiempo de paz venezuela perdió
el 75 por ciento de su masa muscular
en ese interín y en esa caída en el
proceso de la política económica
buscando salir de la hiperinflación el
gobierno se vio forzado a
flexibilizar después de muchos años de
una política
intervencionista estatista de mucha
ineficacia que debilitó de manera
importante todo el tejido en su
industrial venezolano y finalmente
fueron dándose los cambios que eran
inevitables por agotamiento ya de más de
13 años con un control de cambio
inoperante así se fue flexibilizando la
política cambiaria ceder o importó por
tramos la el control de cambios después
se flexibilizó la política de controles
de precio que tanto tuvo que ver con la
escasez y la destrucción de
es de soporte para muchísimas empresas y
ese todo ese proceso fue ocurriendo
simplemente por un reconocimiento
después de tantos años prácticamente 20
años avanzando en la dirección correcta
pero no ha estado
acompañada de un sustento en la reforma
legal y esto es sumamente importante
justamente por el vídeo que presentó
sobre las aspiraciones que desde hace
mucho más de un año está anunciando el
presidente nicolás maduro sobre el
incentivo para inversiones y hay una
cantidad de condiciones jurídicas
delegado de comportamiento que no van a
facilitar esa recuperación la cual el
sistema está perdiendo fuelle que lo
vamos a analizar más adelante tamara por
supuesto lo tengo aquí en mi lista de
temas de la bienvenida a giorgio también
allí en la ciudad de caracas en la
capital venezolana bienvenido al
programa punto de partida porque está
repuntando la economía venezolana desde
su perspectiva cuéntenos
muchas gracias por la invitación
complementando lo que es de cierta
manera el repunte en la economía
venezuela viene principalmente por un
efecto de base muy bajo después de
perder 35 80 por ciento de su tamaño
prácticamente cualquier indicio de
dinamismo en este productiva do
venezolano es suficiente como para
causar un crecimiento considerable
incluso cuando éste esté insuficiente
como para recuperar mucho del terreno
perdido este tipo de crecimiento es muy
desigual y asimétrico ya que está
concentrado principalmente en el consumo
o la recuperación de el sector de
servicios con la apertura por pandemia
en ese sentido podemos ver una dinámica
esperando mayor dolarizados pero eso no
necesariamente representativo del resto
de la economía o extendible para toda la
población hablamos que ahí siento
crecimiento en el sector de comercio de
alimentos de vista profesionales
tecnología salud cuidado personal
pero no vemos repuntes de desanimar está
la gente la minería en el sector
construcción
financiera o también en la en general a
una nueva factura entonces la
profundidad de este crecimiento es muy
limitada y adicionalmente la coyuntura
asiste nosotros con el crecimiento
y también las entradas de divisas podría
remesas si no son bien un componente
importante de una economía informal y
también una economía negra muy difícil
de rastrear pero que ha permitido esta
es la consolidación de ciertas
actividades si en la medida en la que
las autoridades donde rodear las
pensiones internacional yo continúo con
ustedes ya teniendo el panorama claro de
este punto de partida y las opiniones de
los dos invitados paso a preguntarle
giorgio por este crecimiento que genera
muchísimas dudas precisamente porque no
se pueden contrastar las cifras con las
entidades oficiales porque desde hace
muchos años no
y algunas cifras sobre el crecimiento la
contracción de la economía venezolana es
un crecimiento real es un crecimiento
palpable se nota en la actividad
comercial como usted decía que es tal
vez lo que más se está moviendo en las
calles de las ciudades venezolanas es
algo que se está viendo ya en el día a
día cuál es su impresión
el crecimiento si es real la economía va
a crecer en venezuela este año
definitivo al menos con lo que todos los
indica que se pueden monitorear y si la
práctica o pistas lamentablemente son
prácticamente inexistentes para
compactarla la magnitud de este
crecimiento está abajo del arte pero él
ya venezuela pasó por la tormenta por
así decirlo entonces el mero hecho de
que la economía necesita contrayendo o
que los precios no sigan creciendo con
el ritmo hiper intermedio de 2018 ya de
porción la mejora comparativa
metafóricamente hablando venezuela
expediente de una fase de estabilización
el oso en un poco morboso es el
equivalente a un avión que se estrelló
una isla desierta y los sobrevivientes
deben ver cómo resuelven con esto no ya
de la vida exterior no puede seguir
teniendo más el problema está en cómo
salir ante el hecho de que probablemente
no volverá a volar
así que este crecimiento si se está muy
problema es que este efecto rebote fue
uno muy similar al resto de las
economías en américa latina durante el
primer año con la apertura por pandemia
y probablemente vaya a diluirse en el
próximo en los próximos años soy prueba
de la economía de la zona siga creciendo
el problema está de que no lo hará a las
tasas lo suficientemente elevada como
para recuperar mucho de lo que perdió en
el del 2012 en esencia venezuela pasó de
listo tiene desmoronado al piso 20 y con
lo que sea este año probablemente
volverá al 22 todavía les falta mucho y
en términos tanto de tamaño total como
términos per cápita está en la
retaguardia de la región
tamara pasó a preguntarle por las cifras
yo las explicaba un poco al principio en
la introducción del programa las
diferentes perspectivas y previsiones de
crecimiento que hay para este país a qué
se debe esta diferencia de las cifras en
por qué son son por qué la más la
diferencia es muy grande entre una y la
otra no son ni siquiera cifras
aproximadas hay desde 1 por ciento hasta
el 12% porque esos rangos tan amplios
bueno precisamente por una ausencia de
información prolongada en la no
rendición de cuentas es una
característica que tiene en venezuela ya
de más de 20 años de presencia de
sistemática y creciente y la información
que recabamos los economistas y
seguramente giorgio coincidiera no somos
sino unos cazadores de información por
vía de contacto de gremial de clientes
estimaciones de a través de indicadores
indirectos porque déjeme decirle que
venezuela no reportan ni cifras fiscales
ni cifras del sector real como usted ya
lo sabe ni de mí de controles ni de
seguimiento del sector externo ni es
regular en la provisión de la
información estadística sobre precios
que antes tenía todos niveles al mayor
etcétera entonces eso hace el trabajo
muchísimo más arduo y además yo creo que
hay una frase importante que cito ellos
yo que la tomo porque si algo
caracteriza este proceso de reanimación
económica no de desarrollo y
recuperación sólida todavía
es el hecho de una gran desigualdad
entonces todo depende hay una gran
desigualdad entre sectores una gran
desigualdad geográfica y dentro de los
sectores entonces entre grandes y
pequeños de un mismo sector en las zonas
urbanas se nota una reanimación de
comercio que a su vez está notándose
además una especie de llegada a un plato
que tiene cierta preocupación entonces
cuando tú reclamas y pone eso construye
estadísticamente puedes encontrar esas
diferencias y puede haber subjetividad y
bueno en entre toda la gama de de
economistas que proyectan pues diría que
en general hay un consenso a que por fin
por primera vez todas las actividades
económicas este año van a presentar un
número positivo es decir un número del
azul dejó de estar en rojo para nosotros
estuvo en rojo el año pasado levemente
una caída de uno y pico si va a crecer
este año 4%
el 7 por ciento y lo estamos revisando
probablemente discretamente a la baja
discretamente a la baja ya que usted
toca el tema de la desigualdad tamara lo
tengo acá como uno de los temas para
desarrollar en porque usted lo menciona
hay un crecimiento
claro y evidente ya ustedes lo han dicho
pero hay unos sectores de la sociedad
que no está percibiendo ese crecimiento
que claramente les sigue faltando dinero
para poder llegar a fin de mes y para
poder adquirir productos básicos es muy
distinta a la dinámica según hablando
con algunas personas en caracas la
dinámica que tiene por ejemplo el barrio
las mercedes en caracas donde cada vez
abren más restaurantes se nota una
economía en movimiento de la clase alta
en caracas pero otros sectores en la
periferia siguen teniendo estas
dificultades para poder adquirir
productos básicos y bueno ni que decir
de los servicios públicos que tienen ya
bastantes problemas para garantizar el
suministro algunas zonas del país a qué
se debe esta desigualdad tamara porque
el crecimiento no llega para todos y
hago esta pregunta que puede ser muy
básica porque precisamente este lo que
busco con este a poner en palabras muy
simples para la audiencia en américa
latina que no entienda economía que lo
que está pasando allí
bueno primero estábamos en el piso
digamos era una situación generalizada
de
[Música]
debilitamiento de destrucción del
ingreso disponible de las personas y hay
una muy pequeña porción de la población
que si toda ella incluso fuera las
mercedes no caben las mercedes y
entonces hay un encandilamiento cuando
se ven estos comercios ha habido una
agilización y en eso la aceptación
finalmente por parte del gobierno de una
dolarización que todavía es disfuncional
lamentablemente facilitó también la
informalidad a la informalidad a lograr
tener acceso a dólares y mejorar su
ingreso
notablemente pero la disparidad exige
porque este crecimiento y esta
reanimación no es orgánica es una
reacción después de haber llegado al
foso hay una oportunidad de crecimiento
hay un país pendiente por atender hay
una masa enorme de población por
incorporar formalmente a la actividad
económica y eso tiene simplemente que
hacerse de una manera orgánica
generalizada y no con lamentablemente
llamado como la ley anti bloqueo que son
incentivos a la inversión que están
basados en el secreto y las grandes
empresas del mundo en las grandes
organizaciones de financiamiento no
funcionan bajo el secreto sino bajo la
transparencia entonces venezuela no va a
tener ese atractivo en condiciones de
oscuridad y también tiene un legado de
debilidad jurídica y tiene un legado
histórico de un desempeño de haberse
retirado del ciadi que es donde se
aclaran y se dirimen las esferas de
contrato no hay seguridad y claridad en
el ejercicio de la propiedad privada son
una cantidad de cosas todas están en la
cancha de las autoridades económicas son
esas las que van a abrir realmente si lo
hacen y si se logra y lamentablemente
ahí lo político tiene mucha importancia
en lograr acuerdos políticos para lograr
avanzar precisamente en una dirección
donde podamos pensar
las diferencias constantes sociales en
los niveles de ingresos de nuestro país
giorgio retomar la comunicación con
ustedes la ciudad de caracas
ustedes los dos han mencionado que la
economía ya había tocado fondo' estaba
tal vez en su punto más crítico pero que
tanto responde a este leve repunte a una
coyuntura a una coyuntura internacional
una coyuntura puntual y este repunte se
puede considerar como un repunte parejo
es decir abarca diferentes sectores de
la economía usted ya mencionaba que hay
unos que no lo están viendo muy claro
así y es un repunte sostenido puede ser
prolongado o esto va a ser simplemente
por cuestión de unos meses por una
coyuntura puntual
en efecto la coyuntura externa tiene un
impacto especialmente para fortalecer
las finanzas del ejecutivo solamente por
vía del aumento de los precios
petroleros el estado venezolano va a
recibir un incremento más 150 por ciento
de los ingresos por exportaciones de
petróleo comparado con el año pasado
incluso cuando la producción y el nivel
de exportaciones sigue históricamente
bajos eso le da mayor holgura en
términos fiscales de todas formas el
estado se ha reducido y se han pequeñez
y 2 pero la cultura está ayudando al
menos en ese aspecto sin embargo todavía
hay unos temas y ciertas dificultades
debido a que ahora venezuela compite con
rusia para acceder a los mercados
asiáticos ya que ambos aficionados y
también que muchas de las comestibles
del petróleo ven es cuando era
utilizando el sistema financiero justo
al cual ahora también se encuentra
pero sobre la sostenibilidad de ese
crecimiento es una de las mayores dudas
y quizás los aspectos menos alentadores
ya que la economía venezolana es
estructuralmente muy productiva y muy
poco diversificada por lo tanto es un
hecho de crecimiento es relativamente
bajo el efecto rebote y bueno también a
parte de lo que es la reactivación local
natural con la apertura económica pero
es poco probable que venezuela pueda
mantener hasta que se siento elevada en
el futuro sin mayores ganas de propiedad
sólo haciendo un cálculo de servilleta
venezuela tendría que crecer
a la velocidad oa las dimensiones lo que
pueden mirar económico de factor o
segunda guerra mundial para volver su
tamaño del 2013 en menos de una
generación y no hay indicios de que eso
vaya a ocurrir entonces venezuela si
puede mantenerse creciendo pero
difícilmente pueda estar en el 2030 o 35
40 45 volviendo a sus dimensiones de el
2000 del 2013 de igual forma la economía
es de muy poca complejidad y el espacio
orgánico que tiene para diversificarse
estas nuevas cantidades es limitado plan
entonces la inercia con la que la
economía se desenvuelve es una en la
cual no cuenta con los recursos o la
capacidad de aprovechar economía espalda
y ser más productiva más competitiva al
menos como para propiciar el crecimiento
si yo continúo con usted para
preguntarle por esa dolarización de
facto qué tan extendida está tan
extendido está el uso del dólar en la
calle en el día a día en el día a día de
los venezolanos y esto se puede revertir
a medida que la economía vaya mejorando
puede recuperar espacio el bolívar en la
circulación cómo es esto cómo funciona
la organización no se va como una
decisión es visitada de política pública
si no puede uno a medida
la opción a la que adoptaron los
ciudadanos debido al colapso de utilidad
de la moneda de curso legal el bolívar
que perdió churros donde esperaban ser
incapaz de mantener tu reserva de valor
no podía ser utilizado como medio de
pago debido a la ausencia efectivo vayan
en los mecanismos electrónicos tenemos
tiempo con la hiperinflación el
seguimiento de precios los indotel para
la comunidad de cuenta entonces esta
decisión espontánea que ha sido muy
sorprendente muy desigual muy asimétrica
en términos transaccionales llegó a
décadas atrás cerca de más del 60 por
ciento de las prospecciones comercial en
las principales áreas metropolitanas de
venezuela con variaciones por supuesto
en escala regional sin embargo
recientemente con la introducción de un
impuesto a las transacciones financieras
que esencialmente es una lengua
tradicional por transar en divisas
hemos visto una caída a la baja de la
caída de esa proporción estas acciones
tanto en el resto del país como en
especialmente en la capital habiendo
vivido eso la mayoría de las operaciones
en venezuela se siguen realizando en
divisas en términos de disponibilidad
el valor del efectivo en divisa es muy
superior al de toda la liquidez en
bolívares pero el ejecutivo que abierto
muy equivalente en permitir una
organización más profunda está tratando
de revertir la de hecho la organización
no ha sido integrado del todo en el
sistema financiero aunque se pueden
conformarse respuestas custodias en
divisas no se puede hacer transferencias
interbancarias que importe menos
interbancarias en ellos pero se tienen
sistemas lugar en el cual las
operaciones en divisas que son
electrónicas de 18 bis tantos mecanismos
fuera de venezuela
y por último ya para ya para cerrar así
que sea
intención de las empresas de revertir la
dolarización es muy complicado y que
puede tomar décadas como ha sido el caso
de perú uruguay y a fin de cuentas es
una cuestión de confianza el motivo por
el cual es muy difícil ver el bolívar ha
recuperado su mayor como signo como
legal es simplemente porque los pensando
pines deseos de ahorrar en el chip
cámara entonces podemos estar ante una
dolarización completa de la economía
venezolana y del curso legal de la
moneda pase a ser el del dólar en unos
meses en unos años más adelante que
perspectiva tiene usted sobre ese tema
no en absoluto coincido con lo que
señala la giorgio sólo se caracterizaría
nuestra dolarización como una
dolarización disfuncional es una
dolarización incompleta donde los
beneficios de agilización que trajo
fueron ahora revertido por la creación
de esta reforma al impuesto para
desestimular law
el avance es a dolarización eso no va a
avanzar no es el tercero del gobierno
permitir la lo quiere frenar m mucho
tener obligaciones laborales ya están
cumpliendo las que son en moneda
nacional donde digamos hay la facultad
de emitir dinero por parte del banco
central tanto más va a resistirse y va a
evitar que haya una dolarización donde
las obligaciones laborales del estado
sean en dólares y por supuesto porque
pierde esa facultad de financiarse con
dinero creado puesto que los dólares no
se pueden crear localmente por el banco
central del país así que una
dolarización disfuncional no sólo por lo
que decía él en el sistema bancario que
no puedes transferir que no puedes tener
de entre cuenta habientes de un mismo
banco o entre distintos bancos tampoco
hay crédito en dólares entonces es una
dolarización
inevitable que está marcada por lo que
se llama la la demanda de dinero es
decir la no aceptación
la no búsqueda como resguardo de valor
de nuestra propia moneda nacional si
alguien tiene un excedente no lo
resguarda en bolívares incluso con la
desaceleración de la inflación que ha
logrado poner en práctica cuatro años de
una política económica sumamente dura y
restrictiva recesiva también recesión
importantes aclaración esos puntos que
tocan ustedes sobre este tema de la
dolarización tamara quiero que
profundicemos en algo que usted estaba
mencionando en una de sus intervenciones
anteriores y es sobre lo atractiva que
puede ser venezuela para las inversiones
extranjeras que tantas garantías hay por
parte de la legislación usted ya daba
algunos visos sobre este tema y quienes
pueden llegar a invertir en venezuela
qué tipo de industrias pueden llegar
allí
pero el principio no debería decir que
venezuela en términos de potencial de lo
que puede ser es enorme pero la tarea
que hay que hacer es muy grande y no
podemos regalarnos y decir que todo es
culpa de unas sanciones x es
absolutamente falso si levantarán las
sanciones estoy segura que el gobierno
tendría el mismo desafío de hacer
atractivo las inversiones en el país no
para cost para enclaves puntuales
comerciales o de alta rentabilidad en
poco tiempo estamos hablando de
inversiones de desarrollo esas no se
logran
manteniéndose al margen de las prácticas
internacionales
comúnmente habituales no se nombran sin
rendición de cuentas ni publicación de
información estadística regular y
sincera y profunda del país no se logra
incumpliendo compromisos de acuerdos
bilaterales entre países que simplemente
fueron y respetados y no entraron en
vigencia es decir todas todas incluso
las cosas que se intenta revertir
calladamente porque internamente
políticamente el gobierno también al
interno del chavismo digámoslo así
encuentra resistencia a revertir parte
de las expropiaciones que llevaron a la
ruina a las empresas no a sus no fueron
indemnizados en la empresa la empresa en
general fracasaron el gobierno no tiene
la capacidad como ningún gobierno la
tiene de pretender manejar la totalidad
de la economía entonces es el legado de
acciones en contra del clima de negocios
de respecto a la propiedad privada al
patrimonio los acuerdos contractuales
ese no es amnesia es está en la memoria
de la gente y los actos y las leyes
tienen que reformarse para ganar de
nuevo esa credibilidad porque por hacer
tenemos mucho y espacio hay la déjenme
decirle que nuestra economía con todo y
esta recuperación que trae mucho ruido
pero es mucho lo que hay por crecer y
por hacer déjeme decirle que todavía se
puede hablar a nivel de manufactura en
el mejor de los casos de estar operando
a un 50 por ciento de la capacidad sea
hay espacio para abrir pero después de
una destrucción tan prolongada de casi
dos décadas de políticas económicas
debilitadoras restaron esa
competitividad a nuestra industria no
tienen capacidades de respuesta si ellos
no pueden ponerse a la altura y no
tienen capacidad ni siquiera para
enfrentar las importaciones que con
tanta facilidad entra la venezuela entre
otras cosas porque venezuela no puede
crecer mucho más porque tiene un techo
bajo y eso es una frase que dijo giorgio
muy importante la infraestructura de
eléctrica de venezuela y de agua si eso
no es acometido con carácter de
prioridad nacional el crecimiento va a
continuar siendo en consumo de
alimentado básicamente el abastecimiento
con una proporción de importaciones
importante allí se destruyó la capacidad
interna venezuela hay sectores
industriales que están sencillamente
maquilando cuando antes lo insumo eran
adquiridos internamente ahora importamos
caxito varela y la infraestructura es
directamente proporcional a uno de los
puntos de atractivo para para la
inversionista extranjero tener buenos
aeropuertos buenas carreteras buenas
vías suministro eléctrico agua puertos
modernos en ese orden de ideas y giorgio
en ese crecimiento que tanto espacio le
va dando a el emprendimiento a los
emprendedores venezolanos al desarrollo
de hitec de tecnología de desarrollo o
el desarrollo de las startups que son
como la tendencia que uno ve a nivel
internacional que impulsan muchas de las
economías latinoamericanas estas
empresas pequeñas
tecnología eficientes
venezuela está muy atrás de eso o está
como en el nivel de américa latina
eso puede verse desde dos aristas en
primer lugar mucho de lo que es la
dinamización del sector informal está
dado en iniciativas de emprendimientos
pequeños pero estos están concentrados
principalmente en el sector comercio
claro hay algunas historias de éxitos y
también hay
algunos espacios de los cuales estos son
los socios dueños mismos pero el
problema por otra arista es que esto
también puede ser un exceso de
emprendimiento en el sentido que no
estamos viendo ni unicornio en el sector
tecnológico y tampoco mayores
operaciones que tengan inversión
extranjera son unos pocos casos en
esencia es una respuesta ante la
dificultad y el limitado espacio que hay
para conseguir trabajos bien remunerados
en el sector formal entonces esa
dinámica emprendedora aunque es muy
valiosa desde la perspectiva de la
ciudadanía teniendo que valerse por su
cuenta sin esperar al estado
lamentablemente no tiene el músculo
suficiente como para causar mayores
desarrollo especialmente para cubrir por
las áreas carentes de mayor urgencia
como es la cobertura de servicios o la
dotación y adecuación tecnológica en el
sentido el espacio de crecimiento es muy
limitado incluso cuando les piden para
dar se encuentra ahí me quedan pocos
minutos para terminar el programa tamara
quiero preguntarle por un tema no quiero
pisar temas muy políticos pero ese
anuncio de una posible normalización de
las relaciones con colombia que es un
país vecino importante por el pasado
comercial que han tenido y por esa
relación fronteriza ese intercambio
fronterizo esto puede repercutir en algo
positivo para la economía venezolana la
normalización de las relaciones la
apertura de la frontera y volver a tener
el intercambio comercial que había entre
los dos países
bueno hay sin duda es una oportunidad
pero es una oportunidad que también trae
riesgos hay una gran desigualdad de
venezuela como les decía la debilitación
de ese tejido industrial
se tiene que rescatar y no es para
decirlo en términos llanos cuando tú
cierra unas líneas de producción porque
se cayó la demanda porque la recesión
llegó a los niveles en que tan
prolongados en los que estuvo venezuela
tú no la vuelves a abrir desempolvando
una una cosa y volviendo a encender un
switch en un motor entonces en ese
tiempo que ha estado afuera en realidad
el resto del mundo ha avanzado entonces
la competitividad de nuestra industria
no es la más alta en este momento y de
hecho en la zona de los andes hay en el
sector comercial cuando se abre y de
hecho el protector el llamado protector
en ventas irá
cuando abrió hace poco la frontera los
comercios del lado venezolano se vacían
porque hay muchas condiciones que atraen
más a la la adquisición de productos en
colombia bien sea por su precio porque
el bolívar está en términos reales
apreciándose tiene la competitividad y
porque nuestra industria no está en
condiciones de competir en precio de la
misma manera está sometida a muy mucho
muy altos costos si además de eso a una
presión tributaria importante a nivel
nacional regional municipal y de
contribuciones especiales entonces eso
le resta aún más a competitivo y creo
que puede haber beneficios para algunos
sectores y algunas empresas que puedan
tenerse alguna condición competitiva
idónea pero no es
creo que todo el mundo tiene que ponerse
muy atentos para realmente no ser no ser
tomado demasiado terreno por los
productos colombianos creo que va a
sacar más provecho en el corto plazo
colombia que venezuela pues a tamara ya
giorgio les agradezco mucho por habernos
explicado en qué condiciones se
encuentra la economía venezolana
ayudarnos a entender qué significa este
repunte significativo de la economía de
este país después de tantos años de
complicaciones les agradezco por haber
estado con nosotros ustedes pueden
seguir dejando todas las preguntas y
comentarios que desean a través de las
redes sociales sigan con nuestra
programación
[Música]